hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign I guess they're
gonna be doing something a little bit
different I did this a couple months ago
where I showed off one of the new mythic
outfits that was one with the planets I
don't remember if I have the I might
have the effects somewhere on earth it
was the galaxy one and yeah it was this
one but I'm gonna be doing that similar
to how this was except we're gonna be
talking about the new mask outfit we're
gonna be doing some gameplay with rep 43
glad I'm very excited to do it
so yeah in the comments below let me
know guys know if you guys want to see
more of this I plan on doing a lot more
stuff a gladiator since I remember 43
probably gonna have some type of rep 40
duels or anything like that but yeah but
for the agenda they're basically just
gonna play a couple duels with the guy
with this new effect tried to get some
kills stuff like that just a decent
gameplay and they'll probably end the
video right there so as always like the
V if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I cover the informational SATA form
as well do is some gladiator gameplay
but the informational side includes
balance changes hero updates event
changes all that good stuff and with
that let's gonna start with today's
video so the first match are gonna be
going up a against a rep 7 I believe
peacekeeper rep from 100 overall so
pretty damn good fight this probably be
pretty damn difficult I don't know how
I'm gonna be I've never been good
against peacekeeper myself sorry about
that boy it's emailed this out show off
the new emo or show off the new effect
as well never been good with
peacekeepers we'll see how this match
goes go stab
it's like a papa zone off real quick you
get her to move ah good one and good
fight Oh
Sanne said this piece get bring to bed
doesn't some decent predictable attack
something too crazy of course but it's
still a peacekeeper so I gotta watch out
as well let's see you round to let me
guys know in the comments below as well
if you guys want me to do more
commentating stuff so I could tell you
what I'm kind of thinking as I'm doing
stuff like this or if you just want some
just pure gameplay you know I don't care
about my voice I'm getting absolutely
destroyed on I'll stack in the bleed and
everything seems like not really a good
fight at the moment a good fight I got
hit with that bleed pretty damn good now
but now with the new rework of course
you know stacks bleed so that triple
bleed twice really did [ __ ] me up for
about 3/4 of my health I'll try to come
back and ROM 3 of course I'm gonna open
up with off with a bamboozle you know it
never works
try to let that go
kind of [ __ ] up on the Perry there
though I'm getting alleged a good fight
I should've done the heavy summer days I
thought that was a light yeah good one
all right well perfect we've now show
off the execution swimming in the fish
is a little bit it's not too bad I
wouldn't say it's I wouldn't
I definitely probably wouldn't keep this
though I probably keep the idol I don't
mind the mask coming up and stuff like
that
I'm not really big on the execution
though myself
hitter with that decent confirmed damage
this stuff I had me with that zone
that's good was a good attempt get her
with that heavy real quick I meant to do
a zone but I'm kind of glad I messed up
the input on that gonna end the first
game not too bad
peacekeeper was pretty damn good fight
for the first round let's get started
with Game two next blitz gonna be
against a rep one Orochi I believe was
the names only issue with the road
cheese is that with the reflex guard bug
and all this other stuff against
assassins and whatnot is that the some
odd reason he the first three obviously
if he throws the double now it throws
the first light gets the second one
confirmed well for some odd reason the
third one is also confirmed even though
I'm blocking in the same guard stance
it's kind of weird I don't know why this
exists I absolutely baited him with that
zona feint into the toast that what the
confirm like good stuff as a decent
round as I said yeah there's something
up with the road sheet and it's mostly
with Orochi and some and sometimes PK as
well with some of the characters where
even if they throw that other like
immediately afterwards even though I'm
guarding in the same direction for some
odd reason it doesn't it just goes
through my guard I don't know what the
whole point of that is but it's whatever
just have to hopefully get around that
just by spamming my zone attack
easy parry easy parry again thank that
again into the toe step as well with
another GG good stuff well that's one of
the few things you want to look out for
when you're with glad is because as
heavy parry is a guaranteed zone attack
I believe it's also a dashing forward
top light as well but I like the zone
attack and you especially want to keep
an eye on the opponent stamina because
the buckler it takes away the stamina of
the opponent so you can be in situations
where the opponent does have stamina but
through this midway through the zone
attack it basically gets a model stamina
so then you could follow up into the toe
step and then really screw with their
heads of it that's one thing you want to
look out for just like this same
situation he thought he knew it was
coming because it's like the third time
I've done it so from now on I'm probably
just gonna let the zone rip and be on my
way with that type stuff it's just one
of the few things you want to look out
for when you play is glad good hit I try
to go into the buckler hit and see if I
could get some decent stamina off him
it's not really going in my favor at the
moment now I'm a lot of stamina so
what's not too bad I got decent amount
of health I could probably get him one
toe stab and his own attack will kill
him
and we'll just get that will throw the
zone just because I want to get the
execution I'm actually kind of surprised
that worked
usually people guess that though when
you do the zone attack faint into a
guard break although sometimes people
will notice oh it's GG he's gonna kill
me and they just kind of put the
controller down I got super lucky with
that 300 for the second game and we'll
go into Game three up next and four
games were gonna go up against a fellow
glider he's also rep one so hopefully we
can teach this guy a few moves and stuff
like that I'm assuming this is not going
to be a pretty challenging fight but you
never know to it that light it's good
stuff hits with the other light all
right hit it with that zone attack at
that decent damage he had to move right
back with the zone attack I like his
style
damn he's hit me with all these lights I
can't block these do you know if that
top light since we're far away apart
maybe
oh it's a bet oh good hit I was a little
bit early I believe on the Perry Irv was
a little bit late because of the stuff
because of the stun from the buckler I
couldn't really tell what the you know
when it was coming but I kind of I kind
of guessed it but I was a little bit too
or this OGG on that round hopefully let
me get it back get this dub hopefully
gonna start off right quick the top
light I'm gonna go into the next light
and then follow up with the next light
as well and then hit it with the other
lights again just doing that constant
damage pulling it through
hitsue the decent zone that's not as
good stuff those the double light I
caught it it's one of the few things you
don't want to do since that will take a
lot of your health away gladiators
top-heavy is a 30 hit confirmed and it's
the same on the lights are on the sides
and the tops for the heavies so you
definitely don't want to be throwing two
lights as glad because the second light
it's just like any other character that
throws two lights in a row that second
one's gonna get easily paired or block
so it's basically useless so you always
want to start fainting them in different
directions as I was doing in the
beginning with this guy see if I could
pull off a deflect maybe if you whips
out a heavy I'll do it like that
if I did pretty I'm pretty impressed I
pulled off that reflect I'm not honestly
as much as I show it off in streams I'm
not really too great at defects I
usually [ __ ] up the timing a lot even on
most attacks Donuts around 4:00
hopefully we can get this third win
hopefully can win the game as well with
this guy start off the top light again
seems that he seems to run in really
quickly and not guess it good parry he
caught up didn't do the zone attack so
he might not know of the parry punish
which of course is not it's not too bad
cuz of course there's only rep one so he
probably doesn't know that hit the hits
with the heavy attack interesting
they're gonna go for the dashing forward
try and give me some space now we're
standing with that toe step good flight
did yeah it's gonna be the end of the
video guys like I said real quick stuff
is John just sewing off the new mask
outfit that gladiator guy you know as
obviously as well as the other
characters as well one of the huge
things that I like to stress about when
I do these gameplays it showed the
entire gameplay and if I lose in one of
the matches that I'll show in anyway I
got super lucky you managed to get some
decently low rep people and in terms of
the character that they were fighting
except that peacekeeper which got me to
round fly but I still managed to clutch
out the win anyway so I think you're
pretty lucky with the people that I got
this time but I might not be so lucky
next time yeah guys going to be the end
of the vid say hopefully guys did enjoy
if you want to see me commentate over
more of these duels tell me in the
comments bowl and if you don't want me
and I could just add background music
and just have the gameplay shown that's
completely fine as well either way it
doesn't really bother because I'm still
just getting Bulls in anyway with the
new stuff she has subscribed for new I
covered the informational site a
foreigner that bean balance changes hero
leaks hero updates balances like I said
all that type of good stuff with the
patch notes and as well some gladiator
gameplay which I'm gonna start doing a
little bit more regularly now I said I
was gonna do that a couple months ago
but I kind of stopped and fell off but
now we're gonna come back and do that a
lot more now I promise my two most
recent videos will be on screen if you
guys want to check that out with the
guys who were yesterday and peace out